another challenge get connected in any
position
except starting position
i was hoping for like some serious
connect eight so connect eight is like
this
i have no idea who i'm playing so
opponent how do i not
trade off any pawns
it'll give you 10 cents for every center
pawn lossless five dollars for every
blunder plus one okay
uh let's just play every pawn in a
diagonal less 50 cents for every night
move kappa
wait what
every scent of han loss
i don't understand that formula i'm just
going to play normal
if if pawn takes pawn then i
i'm not gonna resign i'm still gonna try
and win
i'll see what uh what my opponent's up
to
yeah okay there there goes my connect
eight hopes and dreams
but okay i'm gonna play solidly i'm
gonna play queens gambit declined we're
gonna develop
we're gonna follow opening principles
rookie 897.
so white's attacking this pawn so don't
want to blunder
i'm also trying to break 2500 i think my
rating
we can't see my rating right now but
it's around
24.60 maybe challenge sacrifice
a queen this game the scheme and win win
50
okay challenge accepted but
that's gonna take some work
i'll i'll probably do it later in the
game
i'm gonna do it later in the game uh oh
we're actually going into like really
interesting opening preparation
so i've studied this exact position as
i'm threatening the pawn
um yeah this is uh this is all prep
i had this exact position against uh
alina kashinskaya in the i am not a gm
tournament it's a beautiful line too
so if e5 i just play rook takes e5
unfortunately white white might resign
before i sack my queen
look at this move it's such a beautiful
move
this is all inspired by casa corley
yeah this is just meeting but can i sack
my queen for mace
white's gonna resign here though it's
it's just force mate or not yet
i guess not yet
it's so nice to play a game too that
like you basically memorize the whole
thing until it's completely winning
um but is it winning
i'm down a rook and white's actually
surviving how is this happening
if i take their queen h2 i guess i could
take the bishop
yeah the game goes on
ooh rook rook d1 is coming
this is not so simple anymore
i still like my position
hey eric the first made a litter spot
that will let twitch chat
vote on the move to play against oh
you if you'd like to use it just let me
know
that sounds cool um do i sack my queen
now
because i could take and take
wait but then my position just dies
maybe c5 play c5
this is getting really iffy
oh c5 is nice because it opens up the
the rank for the rook
so if white ever like gets a rook to the
g file and runs queen h6 i can
i can defend with my rook
i think black's still probably better
it's gonna get crazy though my queen and
bishop are kind of stuck
in front of my pawns ooh i could win
connect four
that's probably too much though
let's play this move
i have a question if rook g1 is this a
queen sack
yeah there goes my queen
i'm winning rooks for it but it's a
queen sack right
i could take this too oh that's more
that's probably more stylish
two bishops
no let's let's give away my queen this
way
oh no my queen
oh this is actually a queen sack ooh
takes takes let's do this and oh no i
can't play b6
hmm wait i'm probably worse now
i sacked my queen i gave in to the peer
pressure
okay i have pawns
i have lots of pawns my pawns
okay so if knight takes i have this move
winning winning material
okay i'm just moving up the board
[Music]
oh it's a nice chain of defense
bishop defends h3
g5 let's go
yes
okay wow that was a tricky end game
that was really tricky
that was really really tricky
that was a fun game that was a really
fun game i mean
so this position is completely winning
whoa
it's it's rishidown thanks thanks for
the [ __ ] congratulations
i appreciate that so just to show
yeah so rookie five is is the best move
um i thought there was game in masters
database
but maybe not this exact position
oh thanks people in the lee chess chat
thanks again russia dan
that was fun i usually don't give in to
peer pressure
but the reward was too great
yeah so casa corley has like a whole
video
explaining this line and oh if we look
up this position
yeah his his game was just insane
because he beat
um he was black against mosenko
who's yeah like one of the strongest
players in the world
at least like top 200 and
he has all the same line and e4 is just
a blunder because of this
this idea
yeah and casa so instead of uh e5 and
rook takes e5
he just played rookie five here it's
completely winning for black
it's incredible oh where did i go wrong
um that's a good question
i actually don't know where did i go
wrong
let's let's just get a quick answer
bishop c5
okay this is all good this is all good
ah queen okay so queen h3 is a really
simple move
but it wouldn't be suitable for the
challenge because we trade queens
the idea is i hit the rook so my bishop
saved and i have so many pawns
have a bishop in four pawns for rook um
yeah if you google casa corley oh i
think the um
the video was on a different channel
than his own it's outrageous
oh this one yeah this video is really
well produced
um it was like professionally filmed too
you can see in the thumbnail like the
same position okay
so yeah say hi to rishidan
in the youtube comments and i hope you
enjoyed that
and i'll see you in the future